vous invitez anthony est albert et les
secrétaire général du conseil
représentatif des français d'outre-mer
et christian vainqueur secrétaire
national délégué unité sgp police fo
bonsoir à messieurs merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
d'abord quelle est la situation où on se
parle en guadeloupe et christian
vainqueur
alors effectivement donc depuis quelques
jours comme vous l'avez dit nous vivons
génération quasi insurrectionnelle où
les citoyens sont privés de liberté sont
privés de leurs droit d'aller et venir
à cause de multiples métiers de barrage
et on n'en voyons aussi des scènes de
pillages d'incendiés des tirs d'armes à
feu par arme à feu dont un en bois des
forces de sécurité
anthony est albert qu'est ce qu'on peut
dire au moment où l'on se parle
justement sur la situation est-ce qu'il
ya toujours des tensions là
haut il est nécessaire d'apporter un
éclairage sur le contexte la
manifestation qui nuise à la liberté de
se mouvoir sont en fait le catalysateur
de passif qui est lourd de déni de
justice
c'est pas au soir
l'interdiction de la vaccination du
moins l'obligation de vaccination et la
mise en oeuvre du cash à lithaire qui
est à l'origine c'est un ensemble de
choses par exemple comment expliquer que
quatorze ans après le scandale du
chlordécone
aucun juge d'instruction n'a été désigné
pour
condamner les coupables que tout le
monde connaît voir il ya même eu un
dossier qui a disparu autres au tgi de
balle qu'on est concevable de voir que
40 ans de stendhal d'eau aujourd'hui n'a
toujours pas trouvé d'issue judici alors
en effet obligé la population à se
vacciner alors que eux mêmes ont dit que
lorsqu'il était au plus fort de la
pandémie de l'aco vide il n'avait ni
masque ni
vaccin et pourtant ils étaient les
premiers de cordée alors moi je veux
bien qu'on dise aujourd'hui qu'il y à
des exactions comme on en trouve aussi à
paris lorsque les black blocks
interviennent et casse les magasins mais
je ne veux pas c'est une stigmatisation
des guadeloupéens des oiseaux peines qui
sont dans un extrême souffrance c'est un
peuple qui est née de la souffrance
historique et qui subit encore la place
seafrance moi je réponds pour avoir été
sur les maras il ya un grand nom
l'acuité politique lorsque vous discutez
avec les personnes qui sont sur les
barrages ils vous racontent leur misère
sociale les compréhensions la défiance
vis-à-vis de l'état la défiance
vis-à-vis des opposants politiques qui
ont été élus avec 19% du doigt les
employés de le faire entonner tel bar
est ce que vous vous attendez à une
nouvelle nuit de violences il ya des
renforts qui sont attendus ya un
couvre-feu aussi qui a été instauré
vendredi est ce qu'on peut s'attendre à
de nouvelles violences afin
de répondre à votre question je suis
consterné par la réponse offerte par
l'état aux guadeloupéens il ya un passif
par rapport aux actions des forces de
l'ordre en guadeloupe en 67 ans 68 et
récemment en 2021 ou claude jean pierre
a été tué lors d'un contrôle de
gendarmerie
et tout cela n'a pas trouvé décision
juridique alors lorsque le gign et le
raid interviennent en guadeloupe comme
médiateurs sociaux jeux peuvent
interroger est-ce que c'est pas une
provocation faite à l'endroit de la
population
ce qu'il faudrait peut-être de mon point
de vue c'est qu' il y ait deux types de
médiation une médiation avec les
services étatiques ou plus haut niveau
ce que le premier ministre après lui
avec les rampes aidera en politique mais
les proposer en politique avec tout le
monde associatif économique et social et
le préfet de la guadeloupe serait bien
avisé de sortir de sa posture martiale
pour aussi réunir les acteurs socio
économiques et syndicaux autour de la
table c'est ça le dialogue on va faire
réagir christian vaquin sur deux points
que vous avez évoqué d'abord le mal-être
aujourd'hui ressenti en guadeloupe est
ce que ça va au delà de la situation
actuelle c'est à dire la la vague
épidémique et les restrictions
sanitaires et deuxième point la réponse
sécuritaire aussi du gouvernement sur
ces deux points là comment vous
réagissez alors je vais je vais d'abord
répondre commencer par le point le point
je suis moi même syndicaliste et je sais
parfaitement que le droit à revendiquer
et le droit de manifester est inclus
dans la constitution française est un
droit
ceci étant ceci étant nous ne pouvons
pas accepter non en tant que
fonctionnaire de police nous ne pouvons
pas accepter que le citoyen soit privé
de leader nous ne pouvons pas accepter
que des citoyens perdent leur bien
perdre leur bien c'est à dire leurs
voitures incendiées leurs commerces
incendiés ça c'est inadmissible
donc il est tout à fait normal que nous
puissions ce état de droit rétablir le
droit le droit d'aller et venir et de
d'avoir effectivement c'est bien
présente
deuxièmement oui effectivement
nous avons une situation sociale qui est
extrêmement tendue tendue dans son camp
dans ce pays doit mieux cette situation
sociale aujourd'hui elle est la
résultante
de ce qui n'a pas été complètement
résolus ou même pas du tout résolu en
2009 et comme l'a dit effectivement donc
pour un intervenant il est venu
s'ajouter à cela effectivement les
problèmes de klondike ans mais cela ne
justifie pas la violence cela ne
justifie pas effectivement aujourd'hui
ce qui se passe en guadeloupe alors il
est temps
effectivement que de se mettre autour
d'une table et de discuter et de
repenser cette fois et selon m et selon
vos pensées vos paiements la réponse
sécuritaire elle est à la hauteur de 2
des événements en guadeloupe est ce
qu'elle est suffisante vous demandez
plus de renforts alors nous voir ce
qu'il manque aux fermes
effectivement les renforts seront les
bienvenus mais nous disons que
aujourd'hui la guadeloupe loin avoir
effectivement une force sécuritaire ou
éviter ce genre de choses et elle doit
avoir une force une force de sécurité
père n est pas seulement attendre que
les gens aient perdu leur bien et qu'on
soit effectivement des cependant dans
cette situation de chaos où nous fait
revenir dans l'hexagone
250 fonctionnaires de police et de
gendarmerie
non il est temps quand même que ça que
cela puisque c'est qu'il est temps que
ça puisque l'enseigné terres derniers
temps oui ce site ceci étant sur le viol
de l'autre le redis c'est vrai il ya des
soucis dans ce pays la tension elle est
là elle est palpable les palpable nous
avons nous avons un pays qui n'a aucune
n'a aucune prospective nous avons un
pays qui n'ont aucune offre
effectivement aucune perspective
on s'est opposé procès pour ses
habitants et en particulier des jeunes
donc il est temps effectivement de la
reporter il est temps aussi que dans
cette république française que le mot
égalité et tout et tout son sens que ce
soit au niveau des institutions ta
présente dans ce département alors
directement que dans la vie en général
c'est à dire que lorsque vous prenez
l'avion de paris à aa la guadeloupe il
faut pas qu'ils aient deux victoires de
différents retardions et pain et visera
pas et pour l'instant c'est ceux qui
courent de malev en guadeloupe et qui
fait effectivement que nous en arrivions
là mais et le dialogue qui est prévu le
dialogue qui est prévue lundi soir entre
jean castex et des élus guadeloupéens ce
que tu as et en crise selon vous
il est laid politique quoi de nous payer
en toute leur plein dans le dialogue
mais je le dis il faut il faut
effectivement que tout à chacun puisse
asseoir de l'attentât seulement les
politiques les partenaires sociaux
également à gwangju elle n'appartient
pas seulement politique je dois de le
payer même si effectivement nous sommes
en deuil et des législatives où le
peuple a voté vous casser ou que ces
hommes et ces femmes politiques tous les
représenter mais à un moment donné où
cette guadeloupe là où elle est
actuellement là où elle se situe elle a
besoin de tous ses acteurs et pas
seulement des hommes et des femmes
politiques pour nous avons au loup
nicoletti de syndicats dont qui sont eux
qui ont appelé donc arabe à manifester
anthony est albert vous réagissez alors
je crois que monsieur vainqueur ne
rejoint sur
l'analyse mais ne va pas juste assez
loin dans les conséquences de son
analyse et les décisions après je veux
simplement lui opposer 1789
la violence en soit on parle même de
violence légitime c'est cette augustin
qu'il l'a théorisé si il n'y avait pas
eu de violence nous ne saurions pas en
république aujourd'hui et c'est grâce à
289 que nous on peut réformer un système
lié à l'exploitation consécutive à la
royauté donc la violence peut avoir un
sens tout dépend si elle débouche sur
une dimension constructive ou pas en
l'occurrence aujourd'hui en effet il ya
des manifestations qui portent atteinte
aux biens et aux personnes
toutefois comme en amour il faut des
preuves c'est aujourd'hui la
concrétisation je dirais même c'est
quelque chose qui est devenu le le fer
de lance d'une trop longue souffrance
sociale dans ce pays donc si on n'y
apporte pas une réponse à la hauteur des
espérances et des attentats j'ai peur
que la venue
de des gens du raid et du dj vj du gign
qui sont vraiment des acteurs de guerre
et de terrorisme ce qu'on ne voit jamais
en france métropolitaine s'exerce sur
notre territoire c'est une violence
symbolique de d'avoir provoqué la venue
de ces forces de l'ordre les policiers
habituel où les gendarmes habituellement
connue sur le territoire aurait été une
réponse plus adaptée et moins
belliqueuse moi ce que je crains c'est
qu'il ya des provocations de part et
d'autre et si le préfet dès dès demain
d'elodie ne provoque pas une véritable
réunion il est probable que ce blocage
se poursuivent donc le monsieur va
curatelle bien que la situation
finalement est ce qu'il faut craindre
s'il n'y a pas une un consensus à un
dialogue qui est entamée et juste pour
mettre fin justement à ces tensions est
ce qu'il faut craindre que cela donne
des arguments à des mouvements
indépendantistes
christian vainqueur
je n'irai pas jusqu'à qualifier la
nature politique et idéologique des
mouvements ce que j'ai aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans un conflit social donc il
appartient au préfet à ce que ce qu'on
peut reprocher au si et quand même
concevable on nous envoie des hauts
fonctionnaires qui sont ignorant de la
culture métal dans l'ensemble des
outre-mer et qui n'ont pas de lettre de
mission il faut que ça change un préfet
ne peut pas venir en guadeloupe en
martinique à mayotte à la réunion et la
guyane comme ils viraient en creuse en
normandie ou ailleurs il doit venir avec
une lettre de mission il doit venir avec
un bagage culturel et historique sur le
territoire d'outre-mer de façon à bien
faire son travail et moi j'appelle de
tous mes voeux parce que monsieur le
préfet
je
n'irai ge dont j'oublie ne puisse
provoquer une réunion le 10 avec tous
les acteurs socio économiques syndicaux
et associatifs sans exclusive c'est le
meilleur signal ainsi anthony atterri
vers juste christian vincent la
précédente question votre avis là-dessus
très très très rapidement alors mon à
mon avis une chose est claire c'est que
jusqu'à présent mes collègues les
collègues
quel japon père soutient d'effectifs ils
ont été
professionnels ils ont évité toute forme
de dérapage
c'est vrai comme le dit effectivement
comme il est effectivement c'est du
chaos bien que bien que vient l'ordre
c'est vrai mais un moment donné il faut
savoir effectivement choisir ses cibles
et pour l'instant ce sont des voix de
lou pays qui souffrent ce sont des voies
nouvelles qui sont ces de souffrir au
lard et d'autre il était quand même de
se mettre autour d'une table et pas et
je ne répète pas seulement les hommes et
des femmes politiques
mais tous les acteurs sociaux et tous
les acteurs
de ce pays voisin merci beaucoup à vous
deux merci à christian vainqueur vous
êtes secrétaire national délégué unité
sgp police fo merci à vous en poney est
albert secrétaire général à du conseil
représentatif des français d'outre-mer